Hey,
what's going on is bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you a little Tarzan,
little Tarzan.
Very little Johnny Weissmuller.
I remember that guy that's back when bead and shake was just not like being fat.
Johnny Moy smelly.
It was an Olympic swimmer and even he was yanking his fucking,
what about the hell he had days?
Little fig leaf over his junky yanked it up past his navel.
Nobody.
Okay.
I challenge you to find one person who was shirtless back then.
You could actually see their belly button.
I don't know.
Okay.
If that was because the naval was considered new to the back then or lewd or the
devil's work.
The Porthole two to,
I dunno.
Getting some pork.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I don't pretend to know these things.
Why didn't I take out my fucking Invisalign?
Why didn't I take it?
I forgot to take the fucking shit out.
I am on train number 11 1111 or 13
Trey 11 and 13 isn't interesting story about train number 11 okay.
I brought it to New York.
All right.
Cause I went back to do the Patrice O'neil,
the sixth annual Patrice O'Neal benefit and um,
which by the way,
I think that was probably the best one we had as far as everybody murdered.
Just a perfect mix of,
of uh,
people that knew him,
people that were fans of them,
black,
white,
male,
female.
Two stories about Patrice comic shitting on each other.
Voss took a fucking pounding.
Hey hosted,
I don't know what he was wearing.
He had this bing Crosby hat on.
Then he had his flannel like a,
I'm going to go see Pearl jam shirt on,
but he buttoned it all the way up.
You know,
like they were going to,
we would joke and like they were going to reboot that movie colors.
Um,
and then he had like these red plastic shoes on that he swore where the shit,
I don't know what it was just one of those deals where it's just like rich,
you have to take one of those things off.
If you're going to button up the flannel and have red shoes on,
get rid of the hat.
Where if you're going to keep the hack,
get rid of the shoes.
If you can wear the shoes and the hat put on a different fucking shirt.
All right.
The Rich Vos is not a smart man.
Okay?
He's driven.
He's dedicated,
but he's,
he's,
he's not always on the right track.
And this was one of these evenings and we tried to tell him he took a good
pounding.
Keith Robinson actually just showed up just to trash people.
He went backstage and Jim Norton was just minding his own business,
eating something and Keith slapped the food right out of his fucking hand onto
the floor.
You know,
the usual maturity.
But I want to thank everybody that came down in the crowd and all the comics,
Sam j who I had never seen before,
fucking murdered Pekori Ellie rich vos safer sounds deejayed it.
Thank you so much.
Jim Norton.
Dave Attell is always,
oh,
the teen idols sensation from the late great opie and Anthony Show.
Robert Kelly,
my old roommate from back in the day,
Jessica Curson,
Greer Barnes and Maureen Taren for putting the whole thing together.
Thank you.
And thank you to everybody who came out.
It was just a fucking awesome show.
Just an awesome show.
I all of them,
they had me pacing and I had to go on after,
uh,
most of them there.
And,
um,
I was just,
oh no.
Oh No.
What did I do?
What did I just do?
He can't even fucking lean back in this God damn place.
Is it still recording?
It is recording,
but I can't hear myself.
Oh Jesus.
Which they had phone there.
It is going to plug it in now.
Most people would fucking edit that out.
Most people are too afraid to look foolish on their own fucking podcasts where
it's just them and they play the producer and all of that bullshit.
But not me,
not me.
So I just,
I had the perfect fucking time.
You know,
I did the west side comedy club,
tuned up there the night before.
Uh,
just so happened Jerry Seinfeld came down,
so I've got to watch him do his set.
Absolutely crushed.
Um,
such a great comedy club.
Right?
It's on 75th and Broadway and between Broadway and Amsterdam,
it's literally right next to the beacon theater and a fucking love that place.
Thank you to the stand for doing the after party and all that as they always do
a,
I might be in New York next week and I'll be down the stand.
I'll let you guys know.
Um,
alright.
Plowing ahead.
So it's the perfect night.
Everything's going great.
We all hang out down the stand afterwards.
They're always so generous.
They've always hosted the afterparty.
They've given everybody food and all this shit.
Just be in the,
uh,
the great guys that they are.
And um,
so the end of the night comes,
I go home and I'm thinking,
what an absolute perfect two days in New York.
And uh,
and I even remembered because I was wearing train number 10,
I even remembered tre number 11.
Cause Wednesdays is when I got to put the new one in.
So the next day I wake up,
I already booked myself a car service,
which I always forget to fucking do.
I break open the bag,
I put trade number 11 in.
Ah,
it's always hard the first couple of days,
right.
I also did the Jim and Sam show had a great time on that.
Um,
just making sure I think everybody,
so anyways,
I put the fucking trays and then I was like,
well,
you know,
I'm dying of thirst here.
The cars coming,
so let me just have a nice light breakfast.
So I go across the street,
I buy a fucking orange and a big thing of water.
So I take the Invisalign out,
I'm fucking eating the orange and all that shit,
right?
Cause you can't eat with these things in unless you're an absolute fucking pig.
Drink the water and all that shit.
And then I just,
you know,
throw all the bullshit out,
right?
And all that type of stuff.
Throw it down the fucking shoot,
grabbed my bags and ready to go.
I still got 10 minutes to spare and then I'm looking for the Invisalign.
Where the fuck is it?
I'm like,
oh no,
please tell me.
I just didn't throw it down that fucking garbage chute with everybody else's
garbage from the building.
Please tell me.
I didn't fucking do that way that
I threw it down the fucking shoot.
So I'm like,
now what do I do?
I can put the old tray back in so my teeth don't move or anything like that.
And maybe I could go home and put train number 12 and that's what the fuck I'll
do it.
Fuck it.
It's gone.
I'm not going down and digging those fucking things out of the trash.
I'm not fucking doing it.
Right.
And then I just sat there and I was like,
you know what?
My wife would she tell me to go down and go get it and fucking just fucking
soaking Listerine for a day.
So I'm like,
fuck.
All right,
I'll do it.
I'm going to do it.
I fucking go downstairs.
Right.
Do you remember a peewee Herman when he ran out of the pet store with the
snakes?
That's what I was like.
So it went down there and the super was there and we'd fucking fortunately no
one through any trash on top of it.
And there was sitting right on top.
Look,
I had a pizza box and something like that.
One of them was in the pizza box,
the other one was sitting right on top,
like a fucking prize,
but still right.
So I just took them through them in my bag.
And then,
uh,
I came home,
I rinsed him off,
scrubbed him with this brush I have,
and then I just threw them in Listerine full like overnight and then said,
all right,
I'm going to pop these in the mouth,
my mouth,
and hopefully I don't get some fucking grown in my intestines.
So,
uh,
that's it.
Pretty Gross.
I'm from a guy who always to said talking about people that fucking walked
barefoot into a public bathroom on a plane.
I actually fished my Invisalign fucking trays out of the trash from my fucking
building.
Uh,
and I'm so ashamed I had to admit it,
but that's how dedicated I am.
Not Jesus Christ.
They seemed fine,
man,
you know,
then,
I don't spill anything.
Nothing it in my mouth.
Been wearing them for like a day or self dare to everything seems fine.
I know it's embarrassing,
but you know what,
what was I gonna I didn't want to fucking jump to the next God damn tray.
I wasn't going to wait for another one.
I want this thing to be over.
All right.
This is how wars are won.
So there you go.
Now everybody knows.
Now the world knows how disgusting it fucking human being.
I am,
um,
whatever or dedicated,
there's all different ways that you can look at it.
So anyways,
I uh,
I flew back on jet blue,
which is the shit and Lisha TV isn't working and everybody else's is.
That was my experience,
but I still had the,
I still had the,
the,
you know,
did share bed thing going on and I just sat there sort of stretching my fucking
arm cause uh,
the right shoulder is actually sit,
sit,
starting to come around it starting to come around.
But I've been so goddamn busy.
I missed all the Olympics.
Oh,
what's the matter?
She upset.
Okay.
Now it's getting that time.
It's getting to be that time of night.
I had a busy day today,
but I've been so busy.
Um,
hang on one second.
Hang on one second.
Wait,
are
we are
ani,
you keep it down a little bit in there.
What are we doing?
Oh God.
Oh,
there was a crisis is
it was a crisis.
So my wife is getting my,
oh Jesus.
You're going to hear a crying.
She just had a fucking little episode there.
You got my daughter's ears pierced.
I didn't want to fucking do it,
but you know,
whatever.
I guess it's,
this is a good time to do it cause they don't remember.
I don't know why she has to get her ears pierced it fucking one years of age.
Like when she read in the news,
you know,
is she presenting at an award show?
Can we just get clip on ones?
What is the rush?
So anyways,
now nia has to clean around,
you know,
where they pierce the years,
so she just went to do that.
She's given Lola bath and Lola doesn't like it.
So she tried to duck out of the way and she put her face right in the water
and she did not enjoy it.
So anyways,
um,
what was I gonna say?
Oh sorry,
I missed all the Olympics,
but I get a,
I,
I thought the gold medal game for the ladies was tonight and hockey.
Evidently it was last night.
And congratulations to the women,
the United States of America for winning the Olympic hockey gold medals for the
first time since I think like 1998 or some shit.
I don't know what that's right.
And when we couldn't have beat a better opponent,
and I'm not talking about the Russians.
All right.
We only compete with the Russians when it comes to blowing up the whole world.
But when it really comes down to hockey,
okay,
it's all about Beaton Canada.
And I actually called because I called up a Vancouver today cause I'm doing some
gigs up there and I did the radio and they were all fucking upset.
They were upset about it.
That's what I love Canada.
That's how much they care Dave and care about women's hockey,
you know,
which I date them.
Not that I have anything against it,
but you know,
down here it's all about the men.
What are the men don't,
we don't care what women are doing unless it's porn or they're playing
volleyball and that's basically how it works in this country.
I'm not saying that's right.
Okay.
But that,
that is how it is.
Okay.
Women's tennis every once in a while does,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno why.
I Dunno why it is.
Okay.
It's just the way it is.
It's all about that stuff.
So wait,
I call these people up up there in Vancouver over there and they're all like,
oh,
you bed called the end of the game.
Oh,
I loved it.
I was,
I was at say,
we want the fucking matter.
Next we're taking the,
the Canadian men's team is next.
I know we already lost,
we got bounced out by checklists about Kia,
I believe.
I believe that's what happened.
I bet the fucking men's gold medals tonight.
I probably should be watching that shit.
But at this year kind of suck because they didn't let the fucking NHL players
play.
DNHL was like on TV,
are going to make some money,
not see Olympics on your continued to escape.
Okay.
I actually,
you know something,
I'm not even give the NHL Shit for doing that because they actually did it for a
couple of Olympics in a row.
They would just shut down the league,
you know what I mean?
And just eat all that money.
And I can tell you right now,
there's no fucking way the NFL would have done that if the,
if football became a fucking Olympic sport,
right?
There's no way they'd be like,
they'd be a normally on zip players if they're going to get concussed,
they are gone the door by they make us the money.
Okay.
Um,
have you,
we'll give you some scallops.
Um,
so anyways,
congratulations to the u s a women,
but winning the gold medal in hockey and uh,
I'm going to sing them a song now.
All right.
Congratulate
play shins to you.
You be the Canadian lady.
We,
you kicked their far as,
even though I miss a gay Bi and I wanna hear about those bad fucking calls at
the end of the gay.
Quit your whining.
You fucking May.
Pecan are whores are better than yours.
I didn't mean to say whore.
I needed a word,
but
one civil syllable,
go fuck yourselves and congratulations to the lady,
sorry,
to the [inaudible] states of America.
How is that does that better than Fergie?
Um,
I actually didn't think that for you.
One was that bad.
I actually watched it on the Jim and Sam Shelf and I thought it was going to be
horrible.
I didn't mind it.
She kind of did.
I read,
I ran one fucking word.
You know what I mean?
I forgive him.
And the rocket's red glare.
Rare,
rare,
rare.
She did something like that.
I didn't know what that part was about the rest of it.
I thought it was fine.
I thought it was totally fine.
Um,
anyway,
speaking of me to,
uh,
I just feel like for me too,
one second to happen.
I just feel like for me,
mmm.
Yeah,
I was in fucking in a cab in Times Square and I'm looking out the windows up and
there was this woman with a fat ass and thick thighs wearing in black leather
pants is tight as possibly could be just walking up the street.
And I know that women,
well,
it's,
it's just like,
it's like what are you doing in Times Square?
Are you Outta your fucking mind?
Why don't you just hang raw meat around your neck and jump in shark infested
waters?
You know,
it's some point,
at some point you gotta be looking out for yourself,
right?
You know,
she looks fucking amazing,
but she was by herself late at night,
New York City Times Square.
Is that what you want to be wearing?
She was probably a cop.
Maybe they got a bunch of meat to cops out there right now.
You know,
trying to get the me too guys.
Is that how it works?
I don't fucking know.
What do you want from me?
Okay.
I just saying a fucking the wrong national anthem congratulating the women and
accidentally called him.
I called them horse,
right.
It just,
I'm sure somebody with hairy legs is going to get upset by that and then that's,
that's how it works.
Okay.
I know there's a lot of fucking problems out there right now.
And they'd be,
and people don't like being being a,
what they call it a hoot.
And Hollering at him,
why they call it,
they call it a woman walks down the street and every guy's like,
oh,
give me a note.
But what do they call it?
Cat Call and all that shit.
You know,
Shit.
That's upsetting.
All right?
But you know,
I would be lying if I didn't tell you it was a little jealous.
Okay.
Cause when I walked by a construction site,
all I hear is the sound of men working.
Um,
you don't think I'd like a standing ovation every once in a while.
Hey,
nice ball,
freckles.
You know,
every once in a while get a little shout out,
make it put a little pep in your step.
Um,
I'm fucking with you.
I don't have any advertising this week.
Can you believe it?
After all the bullshit I've said yes.
Slowly back in a way,
slow.
Lebeck the way I should adjust my tone.
Um,
guess what my fucking drum room is finally done.
I built,
I had this person build me a drum room in the fucking gay Raj and uh,
turned out that was still just a little bit too loud.
I learned a lot of things like 30 decibels
is basically the sound of a silent room with like a light on like the little
buzz of a,
of a,
of a light bulb.
All right,
that's the 30 decibels queef thing is 35 I read on all of this.
Okay.
Like 50 to 55 it's like a light rain,
you know 70 I forget what the fuck that is.
And the nineties when it starts getting annoying.
So my room was built and I was still at 70 right outside the garage.
He walked up the driveway.
You couldn't hear it too much,
but I was like I can't add that.
All right.
So I had somebody else come in and they added this extra shit to it.
And then today it's just like,
it's the shit right outside the garage door is basically the sound of a light
rain and you go up to drive,
you can't even fucking hear it.
So I have the dream bucket drum room.
I can,
if I could play at two in the morning,
and even when you stood outside the garage,
all you can really hear is like the snare drum and it just sort of sounds like
somebody has a stereo one a little bit low.
It's fucking perfect.
So,
um,
that's gonna be what's gonna keep me sane,
I think over the next few years,
um,
as the orange guy in the hairless fat dude sit there pointing fucking missiles
at each other,
you know what I mean?
Trump and what's his face?
[inaudible] face?
I Dunno.
Why don't they just go fucking hang out already?
You know,
have one of those fucking online dates,
you know what I mean?
Just discuss like oppressing people,
just kind of compare notes,
you know,
and then maybe they could like combine what it is that they both do.
Amount of my fucking mind.
People,
I don't pay attention to anything.
Somebody actually said to me,
did you hear about so and so with like the Russians and all that shit?
And I was like,
I'm going to be perfectly honest to you.
I did not.
Oh did they do a probe and what's going to happen?
Is he going to get impeached?
And then what?
Let me guess.
It's going to go to the fucking,
the,
the place where all the people in the suits sit and then they're going to need
three cores of a vote and nobody Republican will vote for it.
And then it'll still be an office.
Isn't that what's going to happen?
I seem to remember that's what happened that time.
That guy took this again.
Oh slick willy.
All Slick Willie.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I don't pay attention to hear that shit.
It's just not a,
I don't find it interesting and that weird.
The fact that I actually find sports interesting,
which are real but don't really matter,
but the actual shit that's going on,
like this guy could get in that level of trouble.
I don't give a fuck.
Um,
I hope people keep sending me Shit in about the,
uh,
about gun control or no gun control or a reasonable gun control.
Cause I find all of that fascinating.
I guess all the kids are going to get together and they're going to do some big
protest.
And I like how people who are into guns and going,
these kids are coached that totally being coached.
Right.
Um,
that's the exact thing that nobody needs,
you know,
I'm not saying that both sides aren't going to try to like fucking finesse their
whole
angle or whatever and that there won't be somebody coached by you.
You should probably listen to people.
I,
you know what I want to know,
I could become fascinated with the fucking a or 50 right?
I mean,
I might buy one before they get fucking band just to,
because it would be worth money.
You know what I mean?
They could,
people buy like,
you know,
when they reissued the Jordan's and people buy them,
they don't wear them and they just stick them in the back of the closet.
So just one day they can just bust it out and everybody's like,
Oh shit.
Right.
Um,
I want to know people have ar 15th.
I know that as people listen to this podcast,
she got one.
Let me ask you this,
what do you do with it?
Okay.
I know what I would do with it.
I wouldn't take it down to some stupid fucking gun range.
And like,
dude,
like target practice,
that's not what you get that gun for.
You get that gun to reenact safely the end of Scarface.
So if I had an ar 15,
what I would do every year around Halloween,
I wait a couple of days after when everybody's Pumpkin's are getting all mushy
and I would just knock on the door and be like,
Hey,
do you want me to take that off your hands?
I'll take your role.
Pumpkin's right.
You know,
put up a sign old pumpkin's recycled here.
Right.
And I get a whole fill up the whole back end of my truck with a bunch of old
pumpkin's.
Right.
And then I would fucking,
uh,
I just take them out in some field.
Right.
I got an ar 15,
you know,
I live in the middle of nowhere,
right?
I fucking take them out into a field.
I put wigs on him and shit.
Maybe a little suit underneath,
depending on how far I wanted to get with it,
you know?
And then just fucking light him up.
Other than that,
what the fuck the avid for?
That's like these assholes who get like a Ferrari and are they just drive it up
and down the sunset strip.
It's like fuck head.
Put It on a truck,
take it to a track.
It drive it the way it's supposed to be driven,
you know?
I mean,
that's what I would do.
That's what the fuck.
I mean he got it.
Don't you want to do that?
You can't tell me somebody anonymously right in.
Just tell me the stupidest fucking thing you did with your ar 15 just having
fun,
you know?
Or if my neighbor piss me off when they weren't around,
I just fucking shooting into the side of his fucking above ground pool.
Get some you mother fucker.
Right.
I would do silly shit if I earn an ar 15 I wouldn't hurt anybody else.
And destruction of property,
you know?
Yeah,
I would do that.
But you know,
women are allowed to get away with that.
Take their fucking ex husband Shit and light it on fire of fucking cheating
boyfriend.
Throw it out in the fucking yard.
You know,
stab it all up.
Cops come down laughing.
They don't give a fuck.
That woman goes back in the house,
they don't care.
They don't give a fuck.
Why can't a man go out every once in awhile and just shoot somebody who's above
ground pool within their 15 is that,
isn't there a re well,
you got to make sure there's nobody in it,
right?
It's also a waste of water.
It's irresponsible.
But you know what I mean?
He can't tell me if there was a youtube video of it would want to see it right
then,
then scroll down and look at all the comments like,
oh,
wastewater much.
And then it means that d flat liberal Snowflake,
a Mofo,
you live out there in Hollywood and that foot and desert.
A couple more comments.
Somebody drops the n word.
You know the basic conversation on Youtube,
right.
Um,
that's what I do anyways.
Uh,
so I don't have any fucking advertising.
I don't have any fucking emails and I got six more minutes to go.
Can he do it?
Can you think of something that he can fucking talk about for the next six
minutes?
What about why do,
why do I gotta think about something?
What about fucking,
you just sitting there listening to us in the next six minutes of your life is
going to go by.
You're going there,
you're never get back and you're going to sit there.
You're going to sit there waiting for me to try to come up with something to
say,
aren't you?
That's where you're at.
Um,
a non gone,
not nine gun people.
All right.
The people want to get rid of all the guns.
They want to get rid of all the guns.
Can you do that?
Is that turning to like get rid of all the straws?
Like how would you do that?
It's like they're out there.
People come in and again,
these are all his straws.
I have,
how would you know that?
You know,
straws are made out of plastic.
Everybody,
which means evidently they never break down.
So just think while the way the first time you went to fucking Mcdonald's,
you're like,
well God,
cocoa chocolate shake.
Just think of the fact that that cup is long gone because it was made out of
paper.
But that Straw that you fucking drank out of with that little thing on top,
it's still fucking there.
It's somewhere.
It's in the ground.
It's out in the fucking ocean,
just swirling around.
I the type of Shit I think about,
you know,
with all these minimalists people gone not fucking minimalist.
It's like,
what do you do with all your shit?
You just throw it out.
So now you don't have to look at it.
It all went somewhere,
right?
That's why you got to have a fucking yard sale.
Jesus Christ.
Just open yourself up to a bunch of fucking cheap costs.
Oh,
maybe they're environmentalist.
Some of this shit that they have out there,
you know,
and this is somebody who fucking as Invisalign out of a goddamn communal trash
bin earlier this week is literally going to sit here and judge people that go to
yard sales and try to find gems.
You know what's really going away as those stores where you just have that
fucking like a hoarder and he says all this random shit and they are like a
fucked up lamp and an old cash register next to like a propeller for some
fucking plane,
you know.
But with those kinds of store I get none.
I antiques things beyond antiques.
It's like modern antiques.
It's just plastic shit.
You know that nobody fucking wants this to be a guy down the street from me.
Dealt all in speakers and shit.
Crazy fucking dude.
Crazy,
crazy motherfucker.
I went in there one time and I had these iPod speakers that I wanted fixed and
he started telling me that he had this revolutionary way that he was going to
record music.
Okay.
And he was trying to tell me,
you Simon and Garfunkel as,
as an example saying nobody really knows what they sound like even if they've
heard the recordings because they weren't recorded correctly because Garfunkel
is like a foot taller than Paul Simon.
So if he was standing in the room,
his voice would be coming at you from,
you know,
eight to 12 inches higher than Paul Simon's voice.
And the way that that would reverberate around the fucking room would be what
they actually sounded like.
Whereas when they go to record them,
it makes them sound like they're both the same height and I'm just sitting
there,
listen to this guy go,
this guy's out of his fucking mind.
But he also might be on to something.
So he was trying to explain to me how the fuck he was going to record that.
And I was just like,
you know what?
As much as this guy seems like he's out of his fucking mind,
he still ended this shit.
He is going to be able to fix these speakers and you know what,
he took my speakers,
you know,
and set them behind the cash register or whatever where I just saw a wall of
speakers
anywhere from fucking,
I dunno,
10 years old to 40 50 years old,
all behind him.
It was like Sanford and sons junk yard and it was all fucking speakers
and a,
sorry like got that dumps sound effect.
It's the only way I can hear if somebody fucking,
since we get texts,
that gum shoe,
wham.
Anyway,
so he takes my speakers and you know what?
He does a never fucking fix them and I kept calling him up.
He didn't even know where the fuck they were and I never got him back.
And he used to drive by a store for two years being like that fucker's got my
speakers and he's going to find one of these cancer yard sales to give him like
25 bucks for it.
One of these days when I got the time,
I'm going to go in there and be like,
hey man,
never.
We took my speakers and you didn't give me a piece of paper or any sort of proof
that actually gave you speakers and you've talked to another 3 million people
since I came in the place.
Well guess what?
I'm back without any proof that I'm telling you.
You got my speakers in here somewhere and I want them back.
I was so meaning to do that and I never,
I never got around to it.
And then one day I drove by and it was just,
it just didn't exist anymore.
So you know what that means,
right?
And let's just go,
I took all that shit.
My fucking speakers right now,
probably in the middle of the Pacific Ocean,
floating around of floating around and they swirling and swirling and eventually
they're going to run into that,
that I hadn't Mcdonald's
and now you know the rest of the story.
Sorry,
did that take a six minutes?
29 seconds ago?
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking bull shit.
I got to get caught up in the Bruins.
I guess we,
uh,
we made some,
we made some moves at the trade deadline.
We got some defenseman from,
uh,
the fuck is it from the,
the,
the New York ranges,
I guess said just packing it in.
They said to hell with it.
Um,
does that mean they're going to get rid of,
Hey Henrik Lundqvist,
you know,
they can't do that.
I mentioned the overhead of that guy fucking shipping all those suits to some
other town and where would he wear?
Can you imagine if Henrik lundqvist ever got fucking,
well,
he got traded to like Columbus,
you know,
with all these Gq GQ clothes walking around fucking Columbus.
Then I'll give a shit.
They barely give a shit about hockey out there,
right?
They're all about the io state Buckeye's now.
That's actually a good hockey town.
I went out there one time for a Redwings game playoff game and it was fucking
great.
Columbus and Nashville,
crazy fence,
great fence.
However,
not exactly the kind of place where you can,
where Henrik lundqvist can wear some of his fancy suits,
you know,
that's a pretty confident move to buy suits like that as a professional athlete,
or you probably think of,
well maybe I'll just wear them in the off season or it helped light the
Columbus,
but I would live in New York cause God dammit I'm going to,
I'm going to wear these buckets.
Suits or maybe you wear the suits in Columbus scene.
Did you show people what the next level looks like?
Um,
I don't know.
I'm talking about he,
they're not even thinking about trading him,
but all I know is we've got a defensemen out of it and we gave up a couple of
draft picks of whatever and I dunno,
the Bruins are like,
hey,
they got the second most points and I'd barely watched the game.
They shit cause I got a little kid and I'm edited into the fucking series.
I did four hours today with the Great Laura dern.
She absolutely fucking murder today.
Um,
she does the voices.
Sue Frank's a wife and I'm,
I'm telling you this season's coming together.
I think I'm going to talk a little shit here.
I think this might be our best season.
I think this is the season where we finally break out of the pack and we get
invited to one of them fucking shows and they give us some shiny shit.
Then we all go up in a big group hug,
you know,
and we enjoy it for eight seconds before they take it away from us and they say,
get back in that room.
And do it again.
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast.
Sorry.
It got a little fucking nuts.
They're just trying to fill time.
I said a lot of things.
Uh,
I meant very little little of it.
Okay.
But that doesn't matter in this day and age.
What your job is to do now is to take it seriously and start talking about how
offended you were in ignore real problems and talk about this podcast as if it
sets swirl a on the belt.
All right?
That's the function has tier.
Sorry,
my brain's fucking fry.
Um,
that's the Thursday afternoon,
uh,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Have a great weekend.
You can't enjoy this music.
And A,
I'll do the whole Trump thing with the index finger and the thumb.
Then make a loop points here.
And then we're going to play a little bit of throwback fucking Thursday podcast
after podcasts from Thursday,
from this year or years before.
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
I almost forgot to say,
are you going to bed?
Little Cutie.
Hi.
Oh,
I you adorable.
Is it even legal to be that cute?
Nia,
you know,
something as far as business goes,
you ever see somebody make a business move and you think,
why didn't I think of that?
All right,
here's my latest one.
Do you know Barstool sports?
Yes.
Yeah,
they're huge.
They're huge.
Do you know what they bought?
There's some sort of like fighting,
I forget even what it,
what it's even called.
It's just like this regular person fight night.
It started in I believe Virginia and just regular people go up there just
throwing haymakers beaten the s side of each other.
Sorry,
my kids here beating the crap out of each other and it's just,
you know,
haymakers very little technique and then they got,
hey Matt.
Hey make maker is
haymaker is actually an expression that came from farming and I can think of was
when you took the sickle and you just swung from behind you to chop it down.
I looked it up one time.
Um,
so anyways,
hey,
why don't you take the microphone?
I've got this all,
I got this,
I got this all set up and now I'm trying to,
okay,
on this one.
So she has an unplugged,
let me just finish this real quick.
So these regular people come in and the fights are crazy cause these people are
just swinging for the fences and eventually somebody connects to somebody.
I'm not saying they're all bad,
but it's just like this crazy,
it's like it's like a bar room brawls.
Right.
Okay.
So barstool sports bought it and then they put it on paper view.
It's like if you,
if you order it early it's 10 bucks.
Who isn't going to buy that and how aren't you going to get your money back?
Are those people that coming in to fire?
Do they get paid?
They get paid.
I don't know what they get.
I don't think there's one to be on TV.
I have no idea.
I don't know how it works.
I don't care about them.
It's all about me.
10 bucks near.
Okay.
I'm ordering that.
I don't know when the next one is,
but I am ordering that and that's one of those things.
What that is going to turn into,
like it's going to be like the regular person UFC and I guarantee you sometime
that's,
that's going to sell for tens of millions if not hundreds of millions of dollars
calling it right now.
Well all right.
No this no we regular,
I'm at a Rogan said one time,
if you just driving down the street and UPC to
people beat the crap out of each other,
you'd slow down and look at it.
What did you rather wash professionals who have trained and have techniques and
have moves?
Oh,
I wish I were appreciate both.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because this is the thing,
even though they're not professionals,
they're really fighting and people really get knocked out.
[inaudible] and this is the thing.
There's none of that.
As far as I could tell,
just the clips I watched,
there's none of that ground and pound strategy.
It's just people.
It's like,
yeah,
cause they're all dislike.
No they're not.
I would not want to get hit by any of the punches.
I saw thrown right.
Is this like that?
But shit that like Kimbo slice used to do like at the backyard,
like guy,
all I saw was highlights.
I was just,
it was like Jerry Springer.
If you edit it out all the crappy,
you just had the fights.
Yeah.
Well cool.
All right.
Maybe you're the wrong demographic.
Yeah,
I could.
I finally was saying something positive on the God damn podcast.
Um,
I,
I couldn't be less interested and yeah,
you don't want to get one of us smoke a joint.
Just watch that.
I'll have a little sippy cup and just,
yeah,
I mean I guess if I'm gonna Watch UFC or boxing and stuff,
I guess I could get into that.
I don't know.
They're just saying,
here's what we're going to do.
The next one of those,
we're going to rent it,
we're going to rent and then you're going to come back on the podcast and talk
about it please.
All right.
That's fair.
You know what?
It is nice.
Nice baby.
It feels exploitative to me.
That's why I asked.
The people who are doing it are getting paid.
I'm sure they get paid.
Probably have some tough man person.
The end of it,
cause it's like there's there,
they're selling it for like $10 each.
These people,
they're whole thing is that they're like not professional,
so it's not like they're going to go on to have a career and fighting.
So what are they?
Here's the thing,
cause if they win,
make sure she doesn't take that and make sure she doesn't take that.
Yeah,
she's pulling it out and I don't think she can get it out.
Oh,
she turns around.
Can you just thank you.
She pushed it all the way into the keyhole.
Amen.
All right.
I don't know.
Well I was excited.
I was excited about you.
You've just got to see it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's still people fighting.
Is it like people?
Yeah.
The people in the UFC get,
do they get exploited?
Do you think they making the lion's share of the money?
They're the ones taking the concussions and all that.
There's been plenty of fighters in the UFC that they're talking about the same
thing.
Yeah.
All right,
thanks.
They're getting paid something.
Yeah.
But you know,
you get to be on TV and it's your,
when you know you're knocked somebody out,
you're on TV and that's pretty cool.
Okay,
sure.
Cool.
Okay.
You know what it's like,
it's like American idol.
None.
Most of those people had no business singing on television,
but what they do and they get to do that.
Right?
Okay.
Is that all right?
Yeah.
But do they have a referee?
Like do they have somebody that's like,
don't kill him?
Really?
You just,
why are you coming at like a mother?
Who Cares?
We don't know these people.
It's entertaining.
Yes,
there's a referee and there's two hilarious announcers.
I have become really soft since having the baby.
It's been a beautiful thing to say.
I'm so soft now.
I'm just like,
oh,
that's not nice.
Don't do that.
Like,
you know,
as you're doing a pushup,
she's uh,
she's doing something.
Are you ready?
You ready for bed?
Qut and not at all.
And she's,
she's loves being in here.
And if she does,
what are you talking about?
You just cracked herself up.
What are you thinking about?
All right.
This is,
this kid is too cute.
I got to get off here.
I've got to say goodnight to my girl here.
I'm all right.
Thanks for coming here.
Let's see.
Here's the deal.
The next one that comes on provided I'm not working.
Even if I'm working,
I'm,
I'm ordering it.
Okay,
we're going to record it.
We're going to watch it.
All right,
and I want to hear what you had to think about it.
I'm 100% wine to do that.
Okay?
I won't cuss.
I'm going to those guys.
Whoever those guys are that,
that run that thing that day going to make an effing fortune off of that.
I think it's going to,
I think it's going to blow up.
Okay.
I'm not as excited about this as you were excited about to see Black Panther and
you're literally doing the exact opposite.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Thank you for listening to everybody and I will talk to you on Monday,
Huh?
Thank
you.
What
is happening in sports?
Can we ate ESPN?
Can we,
you know,
100% access?
Can you dial it back down to like maybe 40% access?
Can you stop interviewing fucking coaches,
Fox and whatever.
NBC as a jogging off to feel trying to think of their halftime adjustments.
Can we just stop fucking doing that?
I don't give a fuck.
Nhl.
Can we stop interviewing players inbetween the fucking,
uh,
periods?
Is it sitting there still out of breath from their last shift and that fucking
drop a fucking sweat hanging off their nose looking like snot that they have to
keep wiping and then it of it comes back again.
Can we just enough?
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
What happened in that first period?
I just watched the first period.
I know.
What happened.
What do you think you have to do in the second period?
Oh,
baby score.
More goals.
Vinnie.
Nhl players listening to this.
Uh,
I'll give you a free podcast tee shirt even though you're going to get fine.
Probably a hundred grand by the league.
Is there any way you could wipe your nose on the blouse of the person who's
interviewing you in between periods?
Just reach out and grab that tie.
Just Dab your eyes,
you know,
I got nothing to give you.
You're a millionaire athlete,
but could you just do it for the,
just for the fucking ridiculousness of it?
Yeah.
Like they're not going to interview you after the fucking game.
Like I have to have it.
They got that fucking guy who stands down there and what looks like the penalty
box in between the fucking benches,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Prince fielder,
the hell's his name.
Prince Harry standing down there.
Well ty,
it's released that ate up down area ice.
Like why do I need to hear that guy
or bash has got to stand up for three periods of his loafers for,
we got hammer toes by the end of the year.
Less access.
Do you think you could do that?
Do you think he could actually start a sports network that could compete with
ESPN and the whole thing is less access
the no miked up players.
You just fucking,
uh,
just trim the fat.
Okay.
Can I just go back to watching Bob Lubell at the end of the news and just seen
five minutes of the shit.
Can I just see that as he sits there in a fucking blaze up,
you know,
every once in a while it takes a day off and new me comes in.
Bob Knew Maya.
I miss those days.
I really miss those fucking days.
Got It.
I
gotta I gotta talk about the on southwest.
So,
um,
I went to Albuquerque this weekend and I had a fucking unbelievable time.
I have not been back there since all those wonderful episodes of a breaking bad
that I got to be on.
And um,
you know,
I was going to go on a hike.
That's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to do that.
But uh,
you know,
Nia had some friends out there.
We were going to go to lunch and you know how that is,
it'll only take like an hour.
That's three hours,
you know,
so I'm just like,
I'm too fucking old too.
Um,
I'm too old to fucking hike and have a social event in one day and then actually
give any sort of a decent,
decent,
uh,
performance.
So I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'm not going to go on the hike.
I'll go over.
And we met,
um,
I met his friends and they were,
they were awesome.
Fucking cooked up burgers the middle of the day,
you know,
those homemade burgers that are way bigger than the ones that you get in a
restaurant and then you eat them and uh,
you don't feel 60 have some stomach afterwards.
Fucking phenomenal.
And uh,
the people's house,
we went over to,
they had all these bears and that type of stuff and I stayed away.
I was a good boy,
so I could have the show,
but I know myself at this point,
so I still that I can't,
I can't do all of those activities in one day.
So I just decided like,
uh,
all right,
I'll just do the social thing and I'll chill out.
Which was actually really cool because I've been to Albuquerque a bunch of times
and I never got to ride around and uh,
see any of it and uh,
it's really,
really fucking cool placement.
Really,
really cool.
Um,
so anyways,
so that night I was at the,
uh,
the 66 casino,
meaning basically route 66 and it's one of the coolest stuff.
And Casinos I've,
I've seen,
I'll try and have some images up for I,
you know,
you try to take pictures of those casino lights and it never comes out on your
cell phone.
At least the one that I have,
the four S.
Um,
but it was really cool,
like the hotel had like that,
you know,
uh,
the route 66 sign instead of the 66,
it just said hotel,
it was all lit up and then,
you know,
it's native Americans own it.
And then the,
the,
the arrows pointing in where to go.
We're literally like arrows and they looked like they were stuck into the
ground.
They will all lit up.
It was fucking bad ass.
It was bad ass.
And then I got to play in the name of the theater was the legends theater.
I played a place called the legends theater.
I remember I was doing some press for it and they said,
what can people expect when they come down to the legends theater?
And it's like,
well,
they should expect to see a legend.
Okay.
It shouldn't expect to see me.
Oh,
fresh out of the fucking horse stable.
Where do I go?
Is this the way to the grade road is not going to be allowed people I'm scared.
Uh,
fortunately it all went,
it went great and a fucking great people out there,
man.
Once again,
and this was another place that was supposed to be a stop on the,
uh,
Billy red state tour.
And,
um,
I dunno for any comics who are listening to this,
don't buy into that horse shit that these are fly over states.
They're beautiful places to go.
And the people are ridiculously appreciative that you showed up this site and
they always say the same shit.
Can you tell this person and tell this person,
you know,
they're always asking for Jim Norton and all these guys that I know from the
opie and Anthony show telling them to come out there.
You know,
we liked comedy too,
so I pass the word on to them and a lot of them have,
uh,
started coming out,
which is cool.
Um,
I just hope that they don't become a and an old jaded like when you play the
bigger cities and they just like whatever,
whatever man,
you know,
I got other things to do,
man.
It was great.
And they actually bought a bunch of DVDs,
which is phenomenal because I got a bunch of them sitting in my garage.
I feel like in my garage is filled with fucking laser discs.
I've got to get those things out of there.
Um,
anyways,
so,
oh,
the dushawn southwest,
sorry,
I'm all over the place today.
So we're flying back,
um,
quick flight back out in 45 minutes.
Fucking phenomenal.
And uh,
you know,
the southwest people,
they always try to be funny,
put a smile on your face.
Most of the times they're not.
And this guy was actually kind of funny.
Then we go to land,
we were landing in Los Angeles and this fucking asshole gets on the fucking mic
and it starts going,
you know,
he's like going welcome to Los Angeles,
which is a a
interesting place.
Yes.
Very interesting.
Kept doing this weird laugh and I'm looking at near,
first of all,
it sounded creepy as fucking hell.
Um,
I don't want to be homophobic,
but the guy sounded gay,
you know,
the gay accent.
And so I used to do a joke on this,
like gay people come from all 50 states,
yet they kind of all have the same accent,
which isn't true.
But generally speaking,
there is a gay accent,
which makes no sense.
How did that joke?
That's how that joke used to go.
Like if you were gay from Alabama,
we were like,
I bought ad.
Really luck to suck your Dick.
Like that's the way you should sound.
Just do a stereotypical redneck accent with my stereotypical gay action.
Right.
But they thought,
I grew up in Alabama and let's just say I'm not going back there.
It's probably more valuable.
You know what the Fuck I'm saying?
That's what the guy sounded like.
So I'm just sitting there on the backhoe and like,
did a,
you know,
this guy get blown in west Hollywood and somebody stole his wallet.
Did he want to be the next Jim J uh,
uh,
buffets,
whatever the fuck the guy's name is from too close for comfort.
I don't know what it's fucking deal was,
but I'm just sitting there on my head going yet another,
the most fucked up thing about living in Los Angeles.
I've never lived in the city where everybody trashes it.
Okay.
Everybody just shits on and that kills me about that.
That's the,
this is the only fucking city where you could do that.
I guess you can kind of make like a gambling joke,
but you can actually land in Los Angeles.
Not give a fuck that everybody,
their lives on the plane for the most part lives there and then just shit on it.
MMM.
I fucking drove me nuts.
Drive me fucking,
I say interesting places to sick.
Well,
what the fuck are you doing?
What makes you such a good person?
What happened?
You hear,
Huh?
What Sit-com did you test for?
And he got to coked up the night before and you fucking blew it.
Ah,
what were we supposed to be on?
Will and grace.
I'm sorry.
In order this,
I'm defensive of La at this point because I have to live out here because this
is the fucking business on it.
I don't have to,
but you know,
it makes life a lot fucking easier to be where everybody else is in this
business.
You know,
if I was into fucking computers,
I go move up to,
why the fucking Nah,
the valley up there,
the silicone valley,
which for the life of me,
I don't know what,
why do they call it silicone,
isn't it?
What's in fake titties?
Is it?
I don't fuck.
Whoa.